>>> NOW TO THE WAR IN UKRAINE.
AUTHORITIES SAY AT LEAST 35
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN INJURED.
THE UKRAINIAN MILITARY SAYS TWO
RUSSIAN MISSILES STRUCK A CITY
IN THE DONETSK REGION.
THE CITY'S MAYOR SAYS TWO
SCHOOLS, A DOZEN APARTMENT
BUILDINGS, AND THREE HOMES WERE
DAMAGED THERE.
THIS LATEST FIGHTING, OF COURSE,
COMES ON THE HEELS OF PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY'S HISTORIC VISIT TO
WASHINGTON TO THANK THE U.S. FOR
ITS SUPPORT, AND, OF COURSE, HE
WANTS TO ASK FOR MORE.
>> YOUR SUPPORT IS CRUCIAL NOT
JUST TO STAND IN SUCH FIGHT, BUT
TO GET TO THE POINT TO WIN ON
THE BATTLEFIELD.
WE HAVE ARTILLERY, YES.
THANK YOU.
WE HAVE IT.
IS IT ENOUGH?
HONESTLY, NOT REALLY.
>> AND JOINING US NOW IS CNN
MILITARY ANALYST, RETIRED AIR
FORCE COLONEL CEDRIC LEIGHTON
WHO'S JOINING US.
I WANT TO ASK YOU JUST HOW WELL
FROM A MILITARY PERSPECTIVE DO
YOU THINK THAT THE PRESIDENT DID
IN MAKING HIS CASE TO LAWMAKERS
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE?
>> WELL, MARTIN, GOOD MORNING.
I THINK HE DID AT EXCELLENT JOB
OF OUTLINING HIS NEEDS, HIS
REQUIREMENTS, AND HIS FUTURE
REQUIREMENTS.
YOU KNOW, HE'S IN A VERY TOUGH
POSITION.
WHILE UKRAINE HAS A DEFENSE
INDUSTRIAL SPARKS IT'S BASED ON
THE OLD SOVIET MODEL.
THEY'VE MODERNIZED A LOT OF
THINGS.
WE SAW A LOT OF THAT AT THE VERY
BEGINNING OF THIS WAR WHEN THEY
USED, FOR EXAMPLE, THE TURKISH
DRONES AND INDIGENOUS DRONES.
WHEN PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SPOKE
TO CONGRESS, HE MADE IT VERY
CLEAR, THIS IS A FIGHT THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE BECAUSE IF IT
DIDN'T CONTINUE, UKRAINE WOULD
CEASE TO EXIST.
I THINK FROM A POLITICAL
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL AS THE
MILITARY PERSPECTIVE, HE DID AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF GETTING THAT
POINT ACROSS.
IT'S NOT A QUESTION OF THE NERVE
ENDING CONFLICT.
>> THERE'S NO QUESTION THE WAY
HE DELIVERED THE SPEENKS
EVERYTHING, EXTREMELY POWERFUL
AND HISTORIC.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID ZELENSKYY
MADE A VERY COMPELLING CASE.
WE'RE JUST NOTING HERE T $1.7
TRILLION SPENDING BILL INCLUDING
$45 BILLION FOR MORE AID TO
UKRAINE.
ZELENSKYY SAYS THAT FINANCIAL
HELP IS CRUCIAL.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THANK YOU FOR BOTH FINANCIAL
MEASURES YOU HAVE ALREADY
PROVIDED US WITH AND THE ONES
YOU MAY BE WILLING TO DECIDE ON.
YOUR MONEY IS NOT CHARITY.
IT'S AN INVOTEMENT IN THE GLOBAL
SECURITY AND DEMOCRACY THAT WE
HANDLE IN THE MOST RESPONSIBLE
WAY.
>> I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT
REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SAID THAT THE U.S.
CANNOT GIVE UKRAINE A BLANK
CHECK.
COULD THIS BE A HINT THAT THEIR
SUPPORT IS WANING?
>> IT COULD BE, MARTIN.
FOR POLITICAL PURPOSES AND
ACCOUNTS PURPOSES, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO HAVE A CLEAR
ACCOUNTING OF WHAT EXACTLY IS
SPENT, HOW MUCH IS GONE AND WHAT
SHOULD GO IN THE FUTURE?
THE PROBLEM IS IT A SIGNAL OF
WAVERLY AND NOT BEING FULLY
IMPLEMENTED IN PROVIDING AID TO
UKRAINE.
IT'S A FINE LINE.
YOU DON'T WANT TO BE LIKE
AFGHANISTAN WHERE PEOPLE WERE
MISSING MONEY AND IT COULDN'T BE
ACCOUNTED FOR.
BUT YOU WANT TO DO IT AT RISK OF
DEFEAT.
>> THERE ARE NEW WEAPONS COMING
TO UKRAINE FROM THE U.S.
INCLUDING THE PATRIOT MISSILE
SYSTEM.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT ONCE
LAUNCHED CAN CHASE ASSOCIATE YET
AIRPLANES.
DOES THIS CHANGE THE WHOLE
DYNAMIC OF U.S. INVOLVEMENT?
>> WELL, THE RUGS WOULD SAY IT
PROBABLY WOULD, HOWEVER, YOU
KNOW, A LOT OF PLANES HAVE BEEN
SHOT DOWN OVER UKRAINE ALREADY
IN THIS WAR AND EVEN BEFORE THIS
WAR.
YOU KNOW, UKRAINIANS HAVE NOT
LOST THE ABILITY TO FLY SOME OF
THEIR AIRCRAFT.
THE RUSSIANS FAILED TO ACHIEVE
AIR DOMINANCE.
THIS ALLOWS -- THIS PATRIOT
SYSTEM ALLOWS UKRAINIANS TO NOT
ONLY MAINTAIN WHAT THEY HAVE IN
TERMS OF AIR DOMINANCE AND THE
ABILITY TO GO IF THERE THERE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THAT.
WON'T GET IT WITH JUST ONE
PATRIOT.
BUT WHAT THEY WILL GET IS BETTER
PROTENGZ OF THEIR SFRAKS AT
LEAST IN CERTAIN AREAS.
THIS KIND OF SITUATION IF THEY
WERE TO SHOOT PLANES DOWN, IT
WOULD PROBABLY RESULT IN A WAR
OF WORDS, THE FIRING OF MORE
MISSILES AGAINST UKRAINIANS BCHL
TU FACT OF THE MATTER IS WHAT
THEY'LL HAVE TO DO.
IT'S SOMETHING UKRAINIANS HAVE
SAID THEY DON'T WANT TO GO
BEYOND THEIR BORDERS WHEN IT
COMES TO ATTACKING THE RUSSIANS,
BUT THEY MAY HAVE TO DO THAT TO
AVOID RUSSIANS A